so today we're going to talk about the
six things that your muscles
will tell you about your nutrient status
fairly quick video but very very um
important if you have any problem with
your muscles
the muscle is an organ and it's a great
indicator of all sorts of nutritional
deficiencies
in the body let's just kind of go
through it all right number one if you
have pain in your muscle
or inflammation it could be vitamin d
deficiency
most people are deficient in vitamin d
it's very very common
and especially if you have low back pain
in general maybe not necessarily in the
muscles but just low back pain
take vitamin d because vitamin d is a
great anti-inflammatory
and it will definitely get rid of muscle
pain itself
okay next thing is low recovery from
exercise so you work out
but you're sore and you can't get rid of
the soreness it takes way too long
it could be an omega-3 fatty acid
deficiency
i'm talking about dha and epa
fish oils cod liver oil you can also get
your
omega-3 from algae and this is very
common as well
a lot of people don't eat enough fish
they don't take fish oils they
definitely don't take olive oil
and so they they may notice that when
they work out it's just
their recovery is very very low okay
next thing is burning in the muscles
and this would also be restless leg
syndrome
that could be a condition called lactic
acidosis where there's too much lactic
acid in the muscle
believe it or not i used to have this in
my 20s
really bad with my lower legs i would
wake up in the middle of night with my
legs
burning and feeling very very energetic
and i had to go
run in the middle of the night to get
this energy out
this is a classic vitamin b1 deficiency
where does this come from well too many
refined carbohydrates and sugars
guilty as charged i used to do a ton of
sugar and ice cream right before bed
and i always wondered why to get up in
the middle of night and have to
you know have this burning in my legs so
it's just incomplete
carbohydrate metabolism nutritional
yeast is is the key
with that and avoid the sugar okay and
the burning will go
away so vitamin b1 gets rid of lactic
acid
next thing is twitching or tetany so you
have a little twitch
you know underneath your eyelid or an
arm it's just this little twitching
that's a low calcium situation now you
could take calcium
and i always recommend taking like a
calcium lactate or a
calcium magnesium type combination not
calcium carbonate
but here's the thing if you're doing
enough calcium
foods like some cheese or even calcium
in the vegetables
it could be not a problem with calcium
it could be that you're
just too alkaline if you're too alkaline
you'll have a problem with calcium
depositing on the nerves
creating a little twitching and
so what you can do is just take apple
cider vinegar and that should
get rid of the twitching very very
quickly
now where does this come from this comes
from
the overconsumption of refined
carbohydrates and sugar
as well as stress those stress
in carbs will create this state right
here now you probably
were thinking it's going to create more
of an acidic state but in actuality
it can create more of an alkaline state
so it's either low calcium or you're too
alkaline
cramps in the muscle that's usually a
potassium deficiency
magnesium deficiency or a sodium
deficiency so you need
salt or these electrolytes
okay i'll start here then go to here and
then go to here
or just take all of these together
next one this is quite amazing
if your muscles are weak and you just
feel like you go up a flight of stairs
and you i don't know your legs don't
move or your legs get heavier
or you just have weak muscles vitamin e
is the fastest thing
to make a weak muscle strong
the the type of vitamin e that you need
is
tocatrinals okay you can get a blend of
tocopherols and tocatrinals
but if you have the option i would get
the tocatrinos because they work pretty
fast
and normally you can get the tocopherols
which is like alpha beta delta gamma
you can get that from your food very
easily but it's very difficult to get
the other part of the vitamin e complex
to katrina's which is alpha beta delta
gamma from the food so you can take that
and
notice how strong your muscles get this
can really be helpful during exercise as
well
so these are the one two three four five
six things that your muscles can tell
you about your nutrient status